okay so this is a TCL 40 next paper and
at first glance it might not appear to
be a particularly special phone like
this is a $200 budget Android phone it's
got a 5,000 mAh battery a pretty
standard issue 50 megapixel main camera
flanked by a 5 megapixel Ultra wide and
a 2 megapixel macro and inside a
mediatech g88 processor 8 gigs of RAM
and 256 gigs of storage this design is
pretty basic it's squared up nothing too
offensive solid blue color with some
sparkles in it but it has exactly one
really interesting feature that's caught
my attention and that's the screen so
this screen you're looking at a 6.78 in
flat 1080p 90 HZ display but when you
put it up next to another phone that's
when you immediately notice something is
very different about it mainly that
there are no Reflections at all none
well almost none so this phone is called
the next paper because it has what TCL
is calling a full color electronic paper
display to deliver a reflection free
full color paperlike visual experience
which looks way better has much less
fatigue on the eyes and also feels
better in the hand and so my first
thought when I first saw this was okay
why doesn't every phone have this like
how is it a how is it a super cheap
budget phone that's the first one I've
seen to pull this off and why aren't
more phones doing this what am I missing
here uh and so of course I had to use it
to get all of these answers so okay TCL
calls it the next paper because they'd
like you to think of it as just like an
eaper display if you've ever seen a
Kindle or any of the other various eink
displays out there that Tech is actually
kind of sick it's amazing it it
minimizes fatigue on the eyes and it
looks and feels like something's
literally printed on a piece of paper
like a newspaper in front of you it
works great in all sorts of different
lighting because it's it's literally
rearranging actual ink underneath the
display but this is actually not that
instead it's an LCD display with a
textured glass on top and some software
tricks to resemble a paperlike display
and deliver almost all of the eye
Comfort benefits that come with it so
the result is basically what looks like
a normal smartphone screen with zero
Reflections and I am very into that like
look at this screen next to a glossy
regular smartphone glass screen
typically when I review phones like I
have to spend a lot of effort shielding
these displays from Reflections that's a
little known fact in this I guess it's
kind of inside baseball but when you
shoot reflective things it is a
challenge I have to angle the phone
certain ways I have to shoot in certain
environments and I often use what we
call a flag here which is literally just
to slide it in at a certain angle to
block Reflections and make the screen
easier to see is a whole thing but with
this matte display I mean I just don't
need any of that special treatment like
it's happy to show up at any angle and
the angles that would normally have a
giant reflection it just kind of looks a
little bit lighter a little faded but
still actually readable and then when
you're straight on or just kind of
regularly reading it's nice and soft and
it's less stressful on the eyes it is
kind of weirdly a little bit paper-like
like some of those paper-like displays
so almost all of this is enabled by
Hardware so there are a bunch of extra
layers between the actual LCD display
and you including this textured glass
and so that's all what gives it this
anti-reflective uh look there's also
some other benefits like physically
limiting the amount of blue light that
makes it through so instead of a special
mode in the software there is just
physically less blue light making it
through an additional filter into your
eyes and another underrated one the feel
I mean literally the way the glass feels
under your finger it kind of has this
soft touch effect thanks to the slight
texture so you can actually see the
difference up at the cutout at the top
you obviously can't do texture glass
over the front-facing camera because
that would ruin the photos not that
they're amazing photos in the first
place but that's the most obvious a spot
where you can see that difference
between the matte finish and glossy
glass and my finger just runs over this
glass almost the same way that it does
on the back of the
phone so I think all this shaping up to
be pretty cool the matte finish the
basically zero Reflections the much
lower eye strain the soft touch finish
there's also stylus supports as TCL
makes stylist that actually works with
this type of screen so what's the catch
why don't more phones have this on them
uh and you're probably one step ahead of
me already which is yeah there are some
downsides so first of all a bunch of
extra layers on the display itself is
going to have some obvious drawbacks but
mainly it's just that they're cutting a
lot of light like it hurts a lot of
sharpness and just Total light getting
through to you so this is the absolute
maximum 100% brightness of this screen
and it's 450 nits so it's good enough to
read indoors as you've seen But Outdoors
it's going to get pretty quickly washed
out and is disappointingly dim now again
this is a $200 phone so I think if this
was an even higher end phone with a
brighter LCD or an OLED back there maybe
it could solve or help some of these
issues but that wouldn't fix the other
one which is sharpness so this is a
1080p display as I've said but it
doesn't even really look like that I
mean I think if I asked you what
resolution you think this is or if I did
a blind test or something it would
compare pretty closely to a 7 20p
display I mean text is soft edges of
things are soft all the corners are soft
it just all kind of has a little bit of
a glow to the edges which again makes
things nice and easy to look at like
nothing is Harsh or super bright or
fatiguing on the eyes but if it's a
Sharp Photo or a video detail you're
after then putting a bunch of layers
between your eyeballs and the actual
display is not the best way to see those
details and then same thing with
contrast just because of how much
brightness is limited the lack of
contrast becomes really obvious this
one's rated at just, 1500 to1 contrast
ratio which even when compared to other
budget phones is not that great oh and
then screen protectors people usually
put screen protectors on their phones
and this one would obviously not make
sense to put a screen protector on so
suddenly in this world of featur Rich
smartphones with all these big bright
clear displays this goes from being an
advantage to being a niche feature
because most people aren't willing to
sacrifice the downsides that come with
maybe a little bit less eye strain and
less Reflections for a matte display
this isn't like a desktop screen where
most people are buying it just based on
the panel and the visual display
properties there's a bunch of stuff
about a phone people care about and uh
turns out people do not like that
trade-off so I've talked about all kinds
of other Niche features in the
smartphone world and how they're awesome
but won't actually sell a ton of phones
this is like the perfect addition to
that pile I mean TCL has these special
next paper modes in the software and
when you turn one of them on one's
called color paper and it goes the extra
mile to you know turn down saturation a
little bit and reduce the extra vibrant
colors it adds some texture and
everything it literally looks like your
like your smartphone screen is like a
colored piece of paper with like your
icons in colored ink moving around and
then you can go all the way up to ink
paper which goes full black and white it
seems silly to most people but when you
compare it to an actual eink display
that's when it looks amazing like an
actual e-reader is the least fatiguing
version on your eyes but if you've ever
used one you know that frame rates are
pretty slow like you you can hardly get
like even a real page turning book
animation on some of the absolute
bleeding edge best versions We have so a
smartphone with a special Hardware layer
that gets close to the same visual level
but is 90 HZ fully responsive full color
and can do anything your phone can do on
top of being an e-reader is technically
awesome which is why TCL also makes a
tablet version of this and another phone
version of this it is super cool but
almost no one's going to buy it and
that's why not every other phone is
going out to do this too at least for
now anyway thanks for watch watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace